today on the matt well show the media
narrative in the jacob blake shooting is
falling apart as the truth emerges the
story we were originally told
appears wrong uh or misleading on a
number of key points and we'll talk
about that today but it doesn't matter
to the writers who consider truth to be
in irrelevant detail
uh to them and same for the media also
five headlines including the nun
at the rnc convention last night sent in
to do battle against the dnc's fake nun
spiritual battle
and there was a clear victor i think and
in our daily cancellation i will cancel
the new york times for an article
that asks us to feel sorry for men who
get caught by police while trying to
have sex with children
yes really uh all of that coming up and
much more packed show today a lot to
cover
we will begin here um only hours after
the shooting of jacob lake by kenosha
police
the narrative had already solidified
that's all it takes these days sometimes
not even hours a narrative can take
shape in mere
minutes but in this case in spite of the
fact that
all we had to go on was a short video of
police
shooting a man while he leaned inside
his car the media had rendered its
verdict jacob blake was an
unarmed victim gunned down by police
after he stopped to innocently
break up a fight between two other
people
well there were questions though was he
unarmed
was he breaking up a fight why was he
reaching into the car
what exactly happened between blake and
the police right before the shooting
and why were the police there in the
first place these were open questions
and now the answers to those questions
are finally uh
coming to light and you know it should
not surprise us
that the answers don't line up with the
narrative as they
uh so rarely do these days so let's go
through what we know first of all
according to wisconsin media outlet
madison 365 which obtained audio from
the police scanner on the night of the
shooting
blake's girlfriend had called 9-1-1 to
report that blake was
at her home um and was not supposed to
be there and had taken her keys and
wouldn't give them back
police responding to the scene were
informed that blake had an open warrant
for his arrest it had been previously
reported rather quietly by the media
that blake was wanted for sexual assault
trespassing
and uh and domestic abuse as well now
this fact alone doesn't directly
vindicate the officers but this
the scanner audio is significant for a
few reasons first of all
um it shows that the eyewitnesses who
claimed that blake was breaking up a
fight
were wrong those eyewitnesses were
apparently lying or if we want to be
generous and see the best in people
assume the best we'll say they were
mistaken the police were summoned to the
scene
because of apparently blake's own
actions of course it shouldn't be a
revelation that eyewitness reports are
often unreliable especially where
high-profile police shootings are
concerned
we should always keep in mind that the
black lives matter organization
rose to prominence on the back of false
eyewitness reports in ferguson about
michael brown
putting up his hands and yelling hands
up don't shoot you know if
it wasn't for that original false report
and false narrative
who knows where we'd be today would we
have all of this chaos in writing
i don't know unfortunately there's
there's even more reason though these
days to doubt eyewitness reports
as these shootings are not happening in
a vacuum witnesses on the scene know
what sorts of things they should say in
order to frame the narrative in an
unfavorable light for police
we don't know if the apparent false
information in this case
was intentional or not but the
temptation to give false information
in this intensely anti-police
environment must be very strong
this is only added on top of the
well-established fact that eyewitness
reports in general
are incredibly inaccurate and that's
something that we've known
for a long time also the flak the fact
that blake had apparently taken
someone's
keys raises more critical questions
about what he was doing
when he walked to the car where his kids
were reportedly sitting and opened the
door with police guns trained on him
was he reaching for something was it
even his car
did he intend to drive away now it seems
there could have been potentially more
than one reason why police would want to
open fire
or would have a reason to open fire if
he was going for a weapon of some kind
that would be clear justification for an
equal response from police
if he has a wanted sexual and domestic
abuser was
about to flee the scene with a van full
of kids possibly involving the children
in a dangerous high-speed chase
that could be another reason for police
to stop him by whatever means necessary
or if the police had reason to suspect
good reason to suspect
either of those um possibilities and
that could be a reason for them too
and then the other shoe dropped later on
later yesterday the wisconsin doj
finally released some information that
filled in most of the rest of the puzzle
we're told that when police arrived on
the scene they tried to arrest blake he
resisted
they tried to use non-lethal measures a
taser he resisted that too
he told them he had a knife in his
possession he went to his car
while they screamed for him to stop he
reached they shot
then they recovered a knife on the
floorboard of his car
so it's a review wanted domestic abuser
uh girlfriend calls police on him police
come
to make the arrest he resists fight back
fights back
goes to his car reaches in knife is
recovered
was he already holding the knife was he
reaching for it was he reaching for
something else and the knife just
happened to be there
there are still aspects of the story
that remain unclear but it's a very
very different story from what we were
initially told
except none of that seems to matter to
the left or the rioters
and we're going to talk more about that
in a minute but first i want to take a
quick break and tell you about
helix sleep you know my experience when
your mattress isn't working for you
uh you can really tell you know you can
tell why you're trying to sleep on it
you can tell when you wake up this is
what happens when you do battle with
your mattress all night you've got aches
and pains and everything
no need for that that's why i have a
helix sleepmaster
mattress and you should get one too the
great thing is helix sleep has a quiz
that just takes two minutes to complete
and it matches your body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress for
you
if you like a mattress that's really
soft or firm
if you sleep on your side or your back
your stomach or you sleep really hot
with with helix
there's a there's a specific mattress
for each and every
unique taste um and and every body type
and everything
you don't need to take their word for it
helix was awarded the number one best
overall mattress of 2019 and 2020
by gq and wired magazine just go to
helixsleep.com
walsh take their two-minute sleep quiz
and they'll match you to a customized
mattress
that will give you the best sleep of
your life they have a 10-year warranty
you try it out for 100 nights risk-free
and they'll even pick it up for you if
you don't love it but you will love it
trust me sleep is a crucial part of
living a healthy life
um and your body needs it in case you
didn't know so take care of yourself
and your body get a helix sleep mattress
right now helix is offering up to 200
off and free pillows with all mattress
orders for our listeners at helix sleep
dot com slash welsh
that's helix sleep.com walsh for
up to 200 off your mattress order
helix sleep.com welsh okay
um now that the truth is uh coming out
about the jacob blake shooting
um you know you would expect maybe if
you didn't know any better that that
would make a difference to the writers
of course it doesn't
it doesn't make a difference to them or
anybody else on the left because truth
and conclusions drawn
have no necessary relationship all they
care about
are anecdotes and stories it can be an
out of context anecdote it could be a
completely
false anecdote none of that matters and
the problem is that when people think
this way
that generalized conclusions can be made
based on random
cherry-picked anecdotes it's almost
impossible to reason with them because
these are by every definition
unreasonable people either not capable
of or simply not
interested in engaging in any kind of
critical analysis at all
here's a great example of that problem
lots of people have sent me a video
which supposedly shows that the blake
shooting was racist
it's not a video of that shooting it's a
different police incident
and one tweet of this video sent to me
meant to debunk my take on the blake
shooting
has over 20 000 retweets and the caption
says
i mean here's a video of a white man
doing the exact same thing and not being
shot once let alone seven times
um let's take a look at the clip watch
he's trying not to use his gun
okay so you have the supposedly
revealing contrast there in one case the
white guy gets in the car
chases after the cop gets in another car
doesn't get shot in the other case the
black man reaching into a car does get
shot what does that prove well
absolutely nothing at all of relevance
all it proves is that
in the first case that particular police
officer
didn't shoot and the other those
particular police officers did
now if you could show me that the first
officer in the first case
has fired on black people in the same
situation
then you might have something but you
would have what you would have there is
only an indictment of that particular
cop not cops generally
these are mere anecdotes different
people different places different times
different situations and two can play at
this game
that's the problem with drawing
conclusions from anecdotes anyone can do
it
and then it becomes an anecdotal battle
flinging anecdotes back and forth across
the divide
as we huddle in our trenches if i wanted
to i could
show you the police shooting of daniel
shaver a white man gunned down
unarmed on his knees begging for his
life
i could juxtapose that against video of
a black man being much more aggressive
and not being shot by cops
maybe i could show you a rioter throwing
a brick at police or something like that
remember that police officer who was
bashed in the head with a brick by
rioters and kenosha on sunday night you
might not remember it because it's
already like it never happened we don't
talk about it
but the attempted cop killer in that
case um didn't get shot i don't know
what his race was but it's a thing
i don't even know if he's been arrested
so could could i look at that and draw
some kind of conclusion about
about the way cops responded no i can't
i've merely shown that in one case
something happened and in another
something else happened to make more
general statements and to form
conclusions on a larger
less isolated scale that's when you
enter the realm of
statistics and you need huge sets of
data and then you need to compare that
data set against the other data set and
you have to make sure that you've
set you know you have set parameters and
you've taken all the various factors
into account that might skew
your results um now as it happens i have
done that others have done it too when
it comes to the issue of uh supposed
systemic racism and policing
you can look at the number of black
people arrested in a given year versus
white people
you can look at the percentage who wind
up getting shot by police if you do that
you'll find the percentage
is nearly identical between white and
black people you can
look at the overall number of unarmed
police shootings every year for all
races
and when you do that you'll find that
it's quite a rare occurrence and most of
the supposedly unarmed shootings or many
of them anyway
aren't really unarmed at all because the
unarmed person was using some other
weapon such as a vehicle to inflict harm
or threaten officers
you can do that i've done it it's the
only way to confirm or disconfirm claims
about systemic bias and racism
one other brief point since we're on the
subject of knocking down anecdotes
uh let's do one more because this one is
is one that i see a lot and it's pretty
annoying because it's so ridiculous
and you've probably seen this too here's
an example a tweet from a guy named
austin duke saying
uh so the f what mad it still doesn't
justify seven damn shots what's so hard
to understand about that
when a mass murderer is taken to burger
king in the country
in this country but black folks dying
over twenty dollars in cigarettes that's
a problem
seven shots isn't acceptable and we
won't accept that
now this is a reference of course to
dylan roof who's the racist
mass murderer um the point being made
here
again at common point is that dylann
roof killed nine black churchgoers in
charleston
and yet was taken alive while insert
whatever cherry-picked example jacob
lake george floyd etc
was killed or shot but what are the
differences
between these cases you might say roof
was white
that's the difference okay sure maybe
under normal circumstances they would
have shot the mass murderer dead
but decided not to because he's white
maybe
or maybe he survived roof did
because he surrendered peacefully and
maybe most
the vast majority of these high-profile
police shootings end up being police
shootings because the suspects in
question
do not surrender peacefully perhaps
that's the difference
and that would explain why for example
the beltway snipers black mass murderers
killed 17 people in a racially motivated
killing spree
were also taken alive because they also
surrendered peacefully
a great many black killers white killers
asian killers hispanic killers
uh all kinds of killers have been taken
by police alive
and the reason is usually that they
surrender peacefully now certainly there
are some
criminals who don't surrender peacefully
and are still taken alive
and if you have proof that black
criminals who don't surrender peacefully
are
significantly more likely to die than
white criminals who don't surrender
peacefully
then show me that proof the burden of
proof is on you as the person
making the claim if you cannot meet the
burden of proof it is reasonable for me
to conclude
that the thing which most determines a
person's fate when they're being
arrested
is how they choose to act in that moment
and that really makes a lot of sense
when you think about it
but why do i waste my breath none of
this matters to the people advancing the
narrative
uh which is while they'll cont which is
why they will continue to
protest for jacob blake raise him up as
a hero in spite of whatever facts are
known or become known in the future
i mean my god they rioted in minneapolis
last night after a wanted murderer
killed himself as police closed in
committed suicide
even that somehow is police brutality
the truth is irrelevant to these rioters
and insurrectionists
they only want to destroy they are
filled with hatred envy and aggression
and they will take any excuse they can
find to let it out
but the truth remains all the same and
we have to continue to speak it and
defend it
and let its banner wave because someone
in this country has to still care about
the truth
and that's the only hope we really have
let's get to five headlines
[Music]
you know i think one thing we've learned
over the last uh several months in so
many ways is that
lots of us we only really think about
getting prepared for an emergency after
the emergency has already happened and
at that point you know you can't be
prepared for it anymore now you're
scrambling to make up for lost time
being prepared means taking things into
account before they happen
and that's why you need ready wise now
is a better time than ever ever to be
prepared with long-term nutritional food
options
uh ready ready wise has options like
emergency meals they have freeze-dried
fruits and vegetables for convenient
on-the-go nutrition they also have
adventure meals for hiking in campus so
it's not just about
emergencies with ready-wise now they've
got meals for all different situations
what i would say is
you know get have some of all of these
um so you're prepared if you
want to go camping or go for a hike but
you're also prepared in the case of an
emergency ready-wise meals are easy to
prepare just add water have a very long
shelf life as well
and ready wise makes being prepared
simple and affordable
and also on top of that the meals meals
are nutritious
uh they're delicious and they are
shipped directly to your door when
government resources are strained
it may be a while before fresh food
arrives due to increased demand
um you know i should also mention for
ready wise supplies are limited
and some items may be currently out of
stock what that means is
you got to go right now and order your
ready-wise meals i have
you know i can tell you i'm stocked up
on ready-wise for emergencies we've got
that set aside um
and then you know we like to go out out
and hike and all that kind of stuff so
i've also i also have the adventure
meals and i can say that they are
you know there's there's a there's a lot
of different like energy bars and stuff
and and
different kinds of meals out there that
people bring hiking i find that a lot of
it
um sort of tastes like cardboard that is
not the case with ready wise these are
delicious meals
this week my listeners can get free
shipping at readywise.com when entering
walsh at checkout or by calling 855 475
3089 readywise is a 990 day no questions
asked return policy
there's no risk taking the initiative to
get yourself and your family prepared
today
that's readywise.com r-e-a-d-y-w-i-s-e
dot com promo code walsh
to get free shipping today okay
so the rnc convention last night night
three i hosted our all-access
watch party i think we had a good time
and i was really happy that our
all-access members had an opportunity
uh you know had the special treat of
listening to
me all night so that was wonderful for
them and there were even a few good
speakers
during the convention as well i thought
um now i'm i'm biased admittedly but i
i thought the star of the night the best
speech
was from sister deirdre byrne she's an
army colonel
a doctor and a nun this kind of sounds
like the beginning of a joke
but it's all it's all rolled into one so
she's all of those
and she got up to speak and she did not
disappoint at all take a listen
while we tend to think of the
marginalized as living beyond our
borders
the truth is the largest marginalized
group in the world can be found here in
the united states
they are the unborn as christians we
first met
jesus as a stirring embryo in the womb
of an unwed mother
and saw him born nine months later in
the poverty of the cave
it's no coincidence that jesus stood up
for what was just and was un
ultimately crucified because what he
said wasn't politically correct or
fashionable
as followers of christ we are called to
stand up for life
against the politically correct or
fashionable of today
we must fight against a legislative
agenda
that supports and even celebrates
destroying life in the womb
keep in mind the laws we create define
how we see our humanity
and we must ask ourselves what are we
saying when we go into a womb
and snuff out an innocent powerless
voiceless life
as a physician i can say without
hesitation
life begins at conception that's that's
awesome and
you know i mean you know i'm gonna like
that that's that is
right in my wheelhouse and i have to
tell you just so you know
if you're not catholic what you just saw
there
that's a a real nun okay she's got the
habit
she's defending the unborn she's very
kind and gentle but you get the
impression that she could whoop your ass
if she needed to
so those are those are nun vibes okay
it's total nun vibes
contrast that with the fake nun at the
dnc
dressed like a secretary praying to the
sky goddess or whatever she
was doing um so you know just all you
need is that contrast and i know which
nun
i'm gonna choose in the celebrity death
match
uh other than that i thought there were
other good moments some good speeches
um i also thought there were missed
opportunities and i think there have
been some missed opportunities all
throughout this are
the rnc convention now they yeah they've
talked about supporting the police
they've talked about the riots and chaos
they've talked about law and order
i think there should be an even greater
emphasis on that i mean we are right now
the rnc convention is happening three
hours of prime time coverage
while um democrats are burning down the
city in kenosha
you know and so i think that i think
there's a real opportunity there
to focus in intensely and show people
what's happening
and you know in with with with
specificity
not just saying oh right at this point
when you say rioting
it almost doesn't mean anything to
people we're numb to it i think you need
to get into specifics and talk about
specific things that are happening
and then call out democrats by name
who refuse to condemn it or who
or who have actually actively encouraged
it
there's been a little bit of that some
of that i think there should be more
okay number two cnn has been a parody of
itself of course for years now but
what i'm about to show you is so
embarrassing and disgraceful that the
phrase beyond parody
scarcely begins to cover it watch
what you're seeing behind me is one of
multiple locations
that have been burning in kenosha
wisconsin over the course
of the night a second night since jacob
blake
was seen shot in the back seven times by
a police officer and what you are seeing
now these images
came and come in stark contrast to what
we saw over the course of the daytime
hours in kenosha and into the early
evening which were largely peaceful
demonstrations in the face
of law enforcement it wasn't until night
fell that things began to get a little
bit more contentious
things were thrown back and forth police
started using some of those crowd
dispersal
tactics like tear gas even playing uh
very loud sounds to push them out
and then what you're seeing the common
theme that ties all of this together is
an expression of anger
and frustration over what people feel
like has become
an all too familiar story playing out in
places
from across the country not just here in
kenosha
wisconsin fiery but mostly peaceful
protests
cnn says as a literal fire rages in the
background
um i i'm you know makes you wonder like
if they were reporting
live from the titanic a pleasant cruise
but a little damp
probably what they would say you know
people sometimes ask questions like
is there really anything new about
biased media
you know did having a media more
interested in propaganda than truth is
that new i mean has it and the answer is
no of course it's not as long as there
has been anything like a news media
it's been biased and and there's been
propaganda
i think the difference now um
between now and other periods in the
past is that
these days the media really just has no
concern for the truth at all period
they aren't even worried about looking
like they're telling the truth
and this largely is a reflection of our
post-truth culture where relativism
reigns supreme
and many of the people in this country
honestly believe that truth is
fluid and can be whatever they want it
to be and the media reflects that
and i think the medium fact reflects it
more than it drives it
the media is a symptom of the underlying
you know moral relativism uh not not
more than it is a a cause of that
let's go to number three as you probably
heard by now the 17 year old who killed
two rioters kyle rittenhouse is his name
has been arrested and charged with
first-degree murder
um and now
we we haven't seen here's what it comes
down to for me
first degree murder is the charge we
haven't seen as far as i'm aware
any video that shows anything other than
self-defense
there are multiple videos out there of
of written house and of the two
incidents that occurred um now if if
there's something floating around out
there
evidence of an actual first degree
murder i haven't seen it
and i've looked there's still a question
mark here
a pretty big one the second shooting the
one that was
caught vividly and close up on camera
that to my mind clearly self-defense
non-controversial he's
falling they're chasing one of the
riders also has a gun
he falls they try to pounce on him he
gets you know then he opens fire
self-defense all the way uh i think i
think that part of it any defense
attorney is going to have no problem
handling that you could hire me as your
defense attorney my
my my legal education involves watching
better call saul that's all i got and
even i could probably get you clear on
those charges
but then you have the first shooting
and that's the one that wasn't clearly
caught on tape as far as i know
i think from what we have seen there are
strong indications of self-defense but
you know i i don't think we fully know
yet here's what we do know though
sadly kyle rittenhouse is screwed
no matter what even if he's innocent
which he very may well he he may he he
uh
he very well may be but even then he's
still he's still screwed
because our media and system is rigged
against
people like him and they're gonna
they're gonna make an example of him
you know it's all the people talking
about problems in the system
they're right there are serious problems
in the system
it's just not the problem they're
talking about
number four the new york post reports
that a taxidermist in england has now
unveiled
his latest work it's called potable
high-five machines
and they're made using limbs uh from
rodents
apparently and reading now from the
article says his inspiration came from
wanting to help people who like to
celebrate and greet each other with a
high five but are concerned about doing
so during coronavirus he said
they're called potable high-five
machines that are made out of rat legs
he said i've been skinning rats to make
other things but i accidentally tore off
one of the legs when i was making and
i was making an abominable snowman which
have heads made from rat scrotums
i don't want to waste it or just throw
it into my tub of odd odd toes and
scraps of ball sack
so i thought so i thought it might be
nice to make a portable high-five
machine
okay well that makes sense personally i
don't know why you wouldn't take your
tub of toes and ball sack
and make like a nice stew or even a dip
uh for your tostitos to serve when your
fellow serial killers come over for the
game on sunday
um now let's take a look at this
creation here there it is
there's the the high five machine
absolutely horrifying
imagine waking up tied to a chair in
somebody's root cellar
and you look around and you see that you
see that right there
what would you think and then you look
to the other side of the room and you
see little snowmen made from
rat scrotum and then you say to the
other person tied up in the room with
you
hey looks like that snowman is made from
a rat scrotum
and they say to you how can you so
easily identify a rat scrotum
and you say because this is my basement
and then you take out your axe and kill
him twist ending you didn't see that
coming
got a little dark there at the end all
right um number five
finally a video has gone viral i'm not
sure who this girl is or even if this is
supposed to be a joke or not but uh
people are taking it seriously
and uh and um are
mocking this girl my perspective on it
might surprise you a little bit i don't
know
but first watch this i was just doing my
makeup for work and i just wanted to
tell you guys
about how i don't think math is real and
i know
that like it's real because we all like
learn it in school or whatever
but who came up with this concept and
you're like pythagoras
but how how did he come up with this
he was living in like the i don't know
whenever he was living but it was not
now
where you can like have technology and
stuff you know
like he didn't even have plumbing and he
was like let me worry about y equals mx
plus b
which first of all how would you even
figure that out how would you
like start on the concept of algebra
like
what did you need it for you know
because like i get
like addition like hey if i take two
apples and then on three it's five you
know
but how would you come up with the
concept of like algebra
because what would you need it for you
know what i mean like what would you
need it for back then
you didn't need it so why would you come
up with it now of course people are
sharing that
and mocking her for being an idiot that
seems to be the consensus but i'm gonna
i'm going to un-ironically and i have to
say that because no one can ever tell
when i'm being ironic or not
so unironically i will defend her here
because what she's posing is actually a
very
intelligent question and one that
philosophers and mathematicians
have been debating for thousands of
years in fact the people that are
calling are stupid have
only revealed their own stupidity you
know
oftentimes you can tell how dumb someone
is
by how they react to an abstract
point or question like this ah that's a
stupid question no it's just you're
stupid
so you don't understand why that's
actually a really intelligent question
um is math real that is not a stupid
einstein wondered about the same thing
was he stupid
there is a debate about whether math is
innate to the universe a fun or you know
a sort of a fundamental facet of reality
or whether it's a human construct in
other words is math
invented by people or did we discover it
entire philosophical theories have been
built around the idea that math is not
innate
that it was invented which is what the
girl here is suggesting
and i don't happen to agree i think matt
is math is innate and mathematics is
just the process of noticing and sort of
attaching symbols to these innate
patterns in the universe
so math is real but symbolic uh you know
we use a little sideways
m to denote the fact that there are
three units of something
um we could use any symbol for that so
that's symbolic but it is still a fact
and uh that there are three or whatever
word and symbol you want to use to
denote it but what the girl is
demonstrating here is a capacity
for abstract thought just the practice
of taking something basic
and questioning why it exists or if it
exists
or why it needs to exist that's a
capacity that i think we should
encourage in young people and i think
one of the problems with the
public education system is that it's not
encouraged you know if you're in math
class and you're learning algebra
and you raise your hand and say you know
and start asking philosophical questions
about
whether this is you know a fundamental
pattern of the universe or whether this
was invented or what what's you know
there's not gonna be time to get into
that with you and you're just gonna be
told to shut up and do your
do your assignment um but these are
exactly the questions that i think
young people should be encouraged to to
think about and talk about
i think most people never wonder about
these things because they're not
intellectually curious and their brains
can't deal very well in the abstract
but when you see this uh i think when we
see this in kids we should encourage it
and not go
you [ __ ] what an idiot and make farting
noises in their faces i i don't think
that's
the right response when young people are
asking abstract questions that's just me
though that's my thought
all right um we're gonna get to our
daily
cancellation uh right now
for our daily cancellation we're gonna
cancel the new york times for
a lengthy article quite lengthy must be
8 000 words or more
just published just published yesterday
here's the headline
convicted of sex crimes but with no
victims an online sting operation to
catch child predators
snared hundreds of men but what were
they really guilty of
now if you think that those of us who
warn of the normalization of pedophilia
and the sexualization of children are
suffering from paranoid delusions
you should really pay attention here the
article talks about
sting operations conducted by law
enforcement to catch sex predators
and it focuses especially on um
operation net nanny which is the
initiative in washington state where sex
predators are lured
to a house to catch a predator style and
arrested although it's not on tv this is
all just
a law enforcement operation but it's
quite clear that the the writer of this
article michael
winarip wants us to feel sorry for these
men who get caught
and he appears to see this tactic of
trapping potential sex predators as
unjust and unfair and we should pity
them for it
um i will say that throughout the
article he does raise a few interesting
points one thing that he dwells on is
the fact that in many cases
men who actually molest and rape
children get lighter sentences
than men who get caught up trying to
molest kids in these sting operations
and i would agree that men who actually
molest kids should get longer sentences
in the same way that a murder a murderer
should get a longer sentence than an
attempted
murderer right but the answer in my
opinion is
extending the sentences for the child
rapist not
shortening the sentences for the
attempted child rapist
so an example that he gives is of a man
who raped a 13 year old repeatedly over
the course of a year
admitted to molesting two of his
siblings
also but god then then was his sentence
was a minimum of seven years
meanwhile another man who got caught in
a sting operation trying to meet with an
11 year old for sex
got a minimum of 10 years now yes that's
absurd the rapist ought to have gotten
more than seven years how about 70 years
instead
um i don't think child rapists should
ever see the outside of a prison ever
again
but a guy who tries to meet an 11 year
old for sex even if there is no 11 year
old because it was an undercover cop the
whole time
is undoubtedly a threat to society and
should consider himself lucky to only
get 10 years in prison for that
so this is the way the article is kind
of set up
and it starts right off the bat giving
us an extremely sympathetic portrait of
a man
who wanted to rape a 13 year old girl um
here is uh here's the picture of the man
along with his mother so i think that
gives you a good idea pretty good idea
of how the new york times wants us to
view this guy
and let me read a little bit of this to
you okay it says
jace hembrick worked as an apprentice
laborer during the weeks
renovating homes around vancouver
washington and at neighborhood gas
stations on weekends
much of the rest of his life was online
he was hardcore amassing a collection of
more than 200 games people told him
it wasn't smart to be so so cut off from
reality but his internet life felt rich
as a dungeon master in dungeon dungeons
and dragons
he controlled other players destinies as
a video warrior he was known online by
his
by his uh nickname and was constantly
messaging fellow gamers particularly his
best friend simon
though the two had never met in person
over the last few years they paired up
as teammates playing rainbow six siege
and rocket league and grew close
um this is this is all in crucial
information that we need about this guy
at 20 hambrick was still living at home
with his mother big surprise there
uh to save money for college where he
hoped to study game design
he was a voracious reader who could
knock off a thousand page fantasy novel
in two days
blah blah blah blah blah etc uh giving
us this whole life story and then
finally
one friday after work in february to
2017 hambrick came across a casual
encounters
w4m women searching for men post that
seemed meant for him
uh just gamer girl sitting home on
sunday it read
we can chat as long as i'm not
leveling i don't even know what that
means as long as i'm not leveling
hamburg emailed back
sounds like fun what game you playing uh
i am hooked on alien isolation gamer
girl replied
forget sex hambrick wrote let me come
watch uh let me come watch i haven't
gotten that one yet
adding that he was 20. 15 years 15
minutes later
gamer girl replied that she was 13.
hambrick was confused
why did you post an ad on craigslist if
you're 13 you mean 23
she asked for his cell phone number and
they switched to texting exchanging
photos
gamergirl was beautiful he thought if he
wasn't being pranked big
eyes cute white caps soft smile gazing
up at the camera serenely with a really
nice set of headphones
they exchanged a few texts about sex i
can be real bad if you're into bondage
he typed
but he was already hoping for more than
just sex i don't get out much he texted
i feel like if we get to talking it
might go somewhere
you're beautiful and a gamer i might
have no problem hanging out with you
that's cool gamergirl replied and then
it gets into even more graphic stuff
with the guy talking about what he wants
to do to her sexually
uh do that is to a girl who told him
he's that she's 13.
now back to the article he it says was
this an elaborate game
again she claimed to be 13 the photo
seemed to tell a different story and the
gaming chair she was seated in
looked too expensive for a kid well
parents could have bought it you know
she used slang a 13 year old probably
wouldn't know like ftp
it means f the police that originated in
80s hip hop
oh yeah i'm sure there's no 13 year olds
that know that the vulgarities and snide
tone seemed too adult her texts were
full of lols
was she an immature teenager or a sly
adult
her driving direction seemed too
specific for 13.
hamburg texted that he would be driving
a red prius his mother's and gamer girl
replied that she would be wearing a gray
sweatshirt and ripped jeans it was a
minute drive to the house um after
stopping for condoms he arrived at 7 p.m
three and a half hours after their first
email
she came to the door just as she'd said
in torn jeans and sweatshirt
and um and then
it goes on and then he goes inside and
that's when
chris hansen shows up or you know
whoever's standing in for chris hanson
um you know the cops come out and uh
and and all of that and they live
happily ever after or the rest of us do
and he went to prison as he should and
the new york times wants us to feel
badly about that
because after all he was never actually
talking to a 13 year old and
he didn't he didn't think that she
looked 13
and uh she knew how to give driving
directions what 13 year old can do that
and she uses lol apparently 13 year olds
don't do that
of course none of this makes any sense
she told you she was 13. what you
thought this was a grown woman
pretending to be 13
and thus trying to attract child rapists
because she's into that sort of thing
now i'm sure there are freaks out there
in the slimy dregs of cyberspace who are
into that but that excuse just doesn't
cut it and shouldn't
a girl told you she was 13.
you came over to have sex with her end
of story
goodbye enjoy prison um
the article makes much of the fact that
these guys who get caught in these
stings
aren't really soliciting minors for sex
because they're actually talking to
undercover cops
it also tells us that a lot of the
predators don't have a criminal history
and many of them don't have child porn
on their computers
we're supposed to be impressed by that
apparently
and then it sort of skims over other
things that are that seem relevant like
the fact that half of the men caught in
this washington sting operation
were trying to meet children 11 years
old and younger
which makes them pedophiles by
definition
now yes there can be gray areas when it
comes to who ends up on the sex offender
registry
you hear about cases for example of say
an 18 year old
in a relationship with someone a few
years younger than him ending up on the
registry even though they're so close in
age they could have gone to high school
together
now that is unjust i think most of us
can agree and wrong
that's not what we're talking about here
20 year old and a 13 year old
no gray area no mitigating circumstances
grown men looking to meet 11 year olds
no gray area
these are sex predators plain and simple
what about using these sting operations
to catch them
well you know is there something unfair
about that
does it matter that they aren't actually
chatting with a real child
no and no first of all if you're told
that she's 13
you're perfectly free and able to say oh
never mind you shouldn't be on this site
kid
go tell your parents and walk away
there's no entrapment here because you
aren't being trapped at all you're not
backed into a corner you can walk away
second catching predators and enforcing
the law
against child molestation and rape and
sex crimes that that's very difficult
um these are not easy laws to enforce
precisely the problem here is that so
often
the laws are enforced retroactively and
the
after the crime has been committed but
then in that case the damage has already
been done to the child
so now we're punishing a predator and
protecting the next victim but it's too
late to protect the first victim so law
enforcement tries to devise ways
to protect even the first victim to
smoke these guys out
and get them behind bars before they're
able to successfully hurt a
child this isn't pre-crime like the
minority report
you are catching people who are actively
trying to commit a crime
it's just that they're trying to commit
it in you might say a controlled
environment it's no different than a
woman
who gets a murder charge for trying to
hire an undercover cop to kill her
husband
the point obviously is that if the
undercover cop hadn't been there
she would have hired a real hit man and
then we'd be arresting her
after the poor sap she's married to is
already six feet under
so what's going on here of all the
problems in the world of all the
injustices to expose
why are we getting a novel length
article telling us about the trials and
tribulations of men who tried to have
sex with pubescent or prepubescent
children
well it goes back to what we said at the
top there is in my
estimation a noticeable effort
underway in our culture to normalize
pedophilia and sexualize children
and to paint the men who prey upon
children as victims of an overzealous
and prudish system
this is just another example of that of
many
and the examples are only increasing and
that is why
uh with great vengeance we must cancel
the new york times
again all right we'll leave it there for
today guys thanks for watching
thanks for listening have a great day
godspeed
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical producer is austin stevens
edited by danny d'amico
and our audio is mixed by robin
fenderson the matt wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20.
the media come up with a new euphemism
for rioters a nun steals the rnc
and a teenager faces jail time for
defending himself in wisconsin
check it out on the michael knowles show